but what if we could stop an asteroid  from hitting in the first place  some of our brightest minds think we can  how does it feel this film  is about the threat of asteroids and  what we can actually do about that it  seems  such a perfect marriage this subject  with imax  it's exciting it's educational we show  how scientists assess whether they're a  threat  what their orbits are what affects their  orbits  and then if they are a threat how we can  mitigate them  there are techniques like the kinetic  impactor which would  impact an asteroid to slightly change  its trajectory  i've never been involved in a filming  where so much effort has been made  to be accurate we want to deliver a film  that's exciting and cinematic  and blows your mind but scientists and  teachers walk out and say hey  they got it right  you